China has a lot to learn to compete with
the us as the world's top gun
but some former British military Pilots
appear willing to offer advice in return
for generous pay packages
a western official says around 30X
fastjet and helicopter Pilots are
working in China right now and more are
being targeted in what one analyst
called a major security breach let's be
honest China is an enemy
um as such we have got a British
subjects who have decided that their
interests are best served by teaching
our enemy how to defeat us this is
incredibly frightening
pilots who can fly Jets like this
typhoon as well as others curiously
haven't broken any laws by training the
Chinese it's an embarrassing loophole
that's quickly being closed including
with new legislation
a Ministry of Defense spokesperson said
all serving and former Personnel are
already subject to the official Secrets
Act
and we are reviewing the use of
confidentiality contracts and
non-disclosure agreements across defense
while the new National Security bill
will create additional tools to tackle
contemporary security challenges
including this one
recruiters have also targeted pilots who
fly the UK's F-35 fast Jets
it has top secret technology a prime
target for Espionage
but officials say they don't believe any
F-35 Personnel accepted the lure of
salaries of around 240 000 pounds
the mod has issued an alert warning
serving and former staff to be aware of
these approaches and turn them down
debraham Sky News